and we are finally live thanks for guys
sticking around guys welcome to the iron
Lords podcast episode number 37 it's
another glorious Sunday and we are back
at the roundtable on the Lord's Day
we've got a very special guest the
murderers row of gaming Capcom and Sami
ACK and destiny 2 PC launched to discuss
so we're gonna get right into it I want
to introduce a Lord whose content I've
been a huge fan of for some time this
Lord is one of the most positive beacons
in our gaming community and his passion
is evident in everything he does from
his informative game reviews epic top 10
lists some of the most heartfelt gaming
rants in the industry and of course that
amazing sega game librarian introducing
one of the top youtubers in a game the
lord of retro game collection amazing
writing and who always tells us to keep
dream love it
guy how are you doing sir man awesome
Thank You soldier having me on this has
been super cool y'all have actually been
hitting me up for a while and I'm so bad
about I get busy and then I forget but
y'all just kept telling me to come on
the show and I've been a fan of the show
so I'm happy to be here thank you so
much for having me so glad to have you
with huge huge fans of you had a like I
said we could city you and Lord at what
you do so it's only right that the Lords
played play that pop proper respect you
know it have you have your own - oh no
man but thanks again for coming through
man you huge fit you trip yeah yeah I'm
happy to dig it we had a bunch of great
topics today so man I'm hype to be here
and of course we have the usual suspects
at the round table
unfortunately my co-host with the co
most he is very sick right now he's
throwing up and actually he's the one
responsible for reaching out the Lord
Dreamcast I'll shout out the Lord addict
get well fellow Lord we miss you
[Music]
[Music]
Saturday and shout out the Lord and come
in for coming to us in our 11th hour
[Laughter]
both the so no game who lives for the
single player selfish experience online
switch profile this week oh yes you do
exist fantastic excited man Friday was
it was a good day for gaming another
little over a week got the ex coming in
so yeah man just good times good times
all around absolutely
CIC even playing I saw that profile was
very very happy 150 moons in we would
talk about that definitely the excess
game the Lord of combat sports was a man
of his convictions and demands nothing
less than the premium experience Oh
beloved Lord King how are we doing sir
we're doing fantastic you guys I know I
don't need to tell you that guys across
the pond was poppin last night and
combat sports also we have the UFC bang
them up bang them out let's get down to
boxing real quick and uh you know cuz
that's the senior guy in the room then
we get over to you you have see a box
Anthony Joshua in the main event versus
to come to calm was a late subbing for
boxing he was fighting which was his
mandatory it was a overmatched fight
again Anthony Joshua I would like for
you to step up and fight somebody
noteworthy please I'll fighting these
tomato cans then you had villain way
fighting another tomato can Eddie heard
you're tearing up box and your
yeah or the schmuck that is the guck
that is messing it all up and over the
UFC I'm high on Bronson
headline I'm high on Bronson and I was
Hannah Bronson going in versus mashita I
thought that he gave Anderson Silva too
much respect in his last fight and to me
he won but he didn't get the decision
because listen he wasn't the name gotcha
but in this fight he went head with no
doubt in this fight mashita tried to do
an inside combo like he does cuz he
counters and man that hit was
spectacular I posted it on Twitter it
was a beautiful knockout it was it was a
it was a done it was done you can
actually watch the whole fight in under
two minutes
um retweeted that out it was fantastic
so yes I had a great time in combat
sports last night next week next week's
card is going to be fantastic
yes the same thing with boxing guys tune
in we have you know listen you see and
boxing is going head up every other
night and this has been one of the best
years that we've ever had in combat
sports it's been fantastic I love the
ride listen I would like to give a shout
out to Plantronics too for hooking up
every last member of the ticke Network I
believe the whole network but I know all
the iron Lords got the headsets they're
beautiful they work fantastic as you can
hear I sound fantastic Dolby Atmos is
beautiful but none of this would be
possible without Lord cog needles
diligent work and effort and pushing
forward and getting sponsors and doing
this so I really appreciate you thank
you so much these headsets are fantastic
and every time I put them on I'm gonna
thank you bro much appreciated okay
that's why you are our resident Lord in
the lord of combat sports
let everyone join and of course
family back at the red tape yes one of
the original iron Lords who helped build
the ILP from the very beginning and our
resident resident PC / mr. bullets brain
himself Bobby no it's what we do exert
doing well good to be back happy to be
here talk soon we got we got some great
topics I can't wait chomping up a bit
he's a t-shirt designer beautiful shirts
the IOP not telling you what you want to
hear but what you need so before we get
into what the Lords are playing I want
to start with Lord Rama then cast his
video game system history including his
amazing passion for Sega games of course
his channel and that keep dreaming human
soul or drink has let's start from the
beginning like we know you we know you
as Lord you guess but was that the first
system the first video game systems but
my first memory ever is actually playing
the Atari 2600 like literally if I go
back into my mom the first thing I can
ever think of is being four years old
and I'm sitting on the floor my dad gave
me Big Bird's big egg hunts so I was
literally I mean you literally catch
eggs and nothing else and I didn't
really discover Dreamcast or I didn't
really discovered any Sega consoles at
all until I was probably 13 or 14 I
lived in like a totally totally Nintendo
neighborhood but as soon as I discovered
Sega it was like this this totally new
chapter the first time I ever saw a
Dreamcast was playing Sonic Adventure it
was just like he was like seen the
anchor because I played so much
PlayStation and I played so much like
Super Nintendo and Nintendo 64 but
that's the first time I saw like super
super like what games that were trying
to have realism instead of just cool
graphics and it really won me over
nice now let me back you up a little bit
cuz you just say so
the Atari right so I want to transition
everything prior to drink at right so so
what was like the first system I guess
that you played consistently after that
after like that Atari
I would say if I can remember probably
the superintendent we had in original
Nintendo but I was very very poor so we
only as far as I remember we only had
Mario and duck huntin on it you know the
combo cart yeah of course we played that
a lot but it was one of the scenes were
since I was born in 1986 even at that
point it wasn't super current but when I
was 5 years old we got the Super
Nintendo and that thing became life I
mean we play really men wrestling games
and Aladdin we used to play a lot and
all the time and that was the first time
I ever saw an RPG was Final Fantasy 4
and it seemed so giant I honestly I
thought that it was playing at a 10 o 64
game on a superintendent I literally
didn't even understand how you could
have a game so big and so well written
even as a little kid I was like oh my
god these are adult games so then all
right a [ __ ] right now did you have
because a lot of the laws here say okay
so I'm just quite like did you have any
subscribe to that but yeah so and what
kind of got me on the whole thing is so
since we were so poor I'd only buy
consoles basically after they were
cancelled and my mom and I buy me a
Dreamcast in 2002 so long ever had
failed but it's this interesting little
toy in one day I was at a party in high
school and I had the Gameboy Advance SP
had just come out and I had the Gameboy
Advance SP and I was playing at this
party because I'm a total loser and they
do a gay masseur this guy watch this to
me and said hey man like I really don't
want to Game Boy Advance SP like I'll
trade you for that even though you just
got it I'll give you a hundred Dreamcast
games and I was like what's it look good
you have a Dreamcast right I was like
yeah but I don't really use it and so he
literally went out to his car and he
came back with 100 Dreamcast game
and so I spent the next couple of years
it's just playing through hundreds of
Dreamcast games since so at that point
they were in stores for like two bucks
each so I just basically became
dedicated to collecting every Dreamcast
game in beating every Dreamcast game and
it was a journey but I did that's our
[Applause]
that was like I actually ran into a guy
just a couple weeks ago like after I
told like dude actually do this big
YouTube thing and I call myself
Dreamcast guy you put that love of
Dreamcast in who's just like those yep
he's like it's no big deal
all right so let's now we fast forward
to that Dreamcast and you got those 100
games you got all that so what were the
would you like standouts cuz the
Dreamcast I know for the Lord a lot of
us it's it's near and dear to our hearts
too
you know we really love that system you
know it just the design of it everything
about it knows launch game so what were
the games that really stood out the Lord
Jesus I think early on one of the first
games that just like melted my brain was
Phantasy Star Online just like it was so
gorgeous for the time like just crazy
beautiful and there was actually there
was a trick in that game where if you
plugged a separate controller into slot
4 on the Dreamcast it would actually be
like a camera you could actually tilt it
around and look around the environment
more freely and saw usually just like
literally clear out an entire dungeon
and they'd just walk around and like
look at the details on the walls
stuff justice it felt like I mean it
felt like the first MMO it felt like the
first met online built game and it's
just I mean it's just melted my brain
that that was possible Casa de chat he's
like well phantasy star online was a
trailblazer it was what it did yeah
absolutely well it and just having a
game that it had an auto translate
feature and stuff so you could actually
go online and and play with people from
Japan and it would translated a really
bad gobbledygook but it was you know and
it was also one of the first times I
ever got an argument to people online
because people would people like you
have a giant boss fight and it would
just spew out like a bunch of like
really expensive guns and people just
start hammering a and grabbing all the
guns it's new like hate like typing out
I was so bad at typing I used to put
type like hey [ __ ] that is who cares
loot I know uh from for me uh Shenmue
was did you play any Shenmue at all did
you
yes get into it yes I played Shenmue one
and I actually such our core Dreamcast
collector I imported the European
version of Dreamcast new so I played I
got to actually play the original
version of it on all four discs and wow
it's just such an experience and it was
so weird so I ended up beating Shenmue
one and two back to back with and like a
couple month period and since it is such
a cliffhanger ending I remember the
second Shenmue 2 ended I actually sat
down and I wrote a hand wrote a letter
to Sega in Japan asking them to make a
Shenmue 3 I think this was probably like
I says it's what he said because it for
us like looking at tell you like I
remember when he brought Shenmue over
tomorrow for the first time they like we
dim the lights and it was like the
cinematic and we were already martial
arts fans as it was it was like the
first gating graphically they had like
that virtual fighters engine 3d air
easing and it was just that whole
cinematic between you know ryos pop and
um Landy and just a sudden call it was
we were like blown away like that got ya
the sleep you had to get a job yeah the
party as probably was an arcade when it
had literally emulations of classic city
games like come run and you know thank
you that game had so much hidden stuff
as well that you have to like basically
buy the strategy when you buy the
strategy guide the official strategy
guide had a sealed part at the back that
said warning if you break this you're
gonna discover all the secrets of the
game and you'd open it up and it told
you that you could go down to the store
and there was actually like there was
all those candy and stuff you could buy
and there was a particular candy all the
way at the end that had a red box and it
said lottery candy and like every
fifteenth piece you'd win a prize and
the most rare prize was actually Sega
Saturn games you could go back to Sega
Saturn out of reuse room it's like in
his living room
you actually hook it up but you can only
keep it hooked up if you have Sega
Saturn games you actually put them in
there and it lets you play like a
different version of outlet stuff yes
yeah yes well it was one thing so it is
so crazy to be like how the hell like
man it was just crazy it's crazy wow wow
I let get some information every day
this going to the Saturn there really
quickly says that mean is is that
anything that you have an affinity for
love war or yes now but I only
discovered that in 2013 I finally
decided to start collecting for cos at
that point I had every Dreamcast game
I've had about a hundred Sega Genesis
games some Master System stuff and I
have about 20 32x games and so I was
like oh well there's this other disk
based system that I've literally never
played I'd never even seen that Sega
Saturn in my life until I bought one and
so the first time I ever stumble on one
this guy was selling it at like a crappy
flea market he was like oh I'm missing
the wires but it's this and 10 10 loose
copies of Frankenstein like you wanted
for 50 bucks or I was like yeah sure so
now I have a bunch of loose like really
bad loose Sega Saturn games but I
actually got about 25 second game
now some of the rare ones I like I've
got like a stall and stuff is so good
and it's it's weird that it's so good
like cuz it's so polished and the music
is so addictive and a level design is so
good as well as it's so weird than that
it just got so overlooked like it is an
amazing freaking game and you don't they
they came out with it and then it's
sequels 16 months later because the
fridge bombed so hard they're like
alright you have to make another right
now we're not gonna break even check
clockwork now at night so is some great
ones that people think the chat is
warming up man and they're loving these
gags yes yeah what and I end up getting
a bunch of that I imported some of the
2d fighters and I imported a bunch of
Japanese Sega Saturn games because
they're dirt cheap and you actually
still play them so I got the Japanese
version of grandia cuz I'm obsessed with
RPGs I got yes there's a bomber game one
of the only bummer mains that didn't
come to America is called super
Bomberman fights and it's like it's nice
and metric he looks super weird but I
saw you ended up doing that so yeah big
steak a Saturn fan it's not to get good
gaming the Jays like damnit I have to
get us a Saturn I guess so obviously we
know how mean India that was too hard so
as gaming went on for the next
transitionary steps from as far as the
next systems that you got well I ended
up getting an original Xbox I live next
this even though I live in a really poor
part of town as a kid the kid next to me
for some reason at one point he and he
inherited like a couple hundred thousand
dollars but since he was like 16 he
didn't really do anything with it except
he bought like a Mustang and he ended up
buying me an original Xbox with halo and
mech assault and it was this crazy like
I opening experience of like whoa this
is this is so cool so I ended up just
playing hundreds of hours of Halo I end
up going to a bunch of low tournaments I
even buy so basically joined a Halo team
and so for the next couple years I
literally paid my bills winning at halo
tournament
stop wow that's pretty cool yeah
yesterday I noticed a lot of you know
people who either grow up with shake or
say kids kind of like it almost seems
like the natural evolution for them was
Xbox for some reason I ended up
researching and I found out that a lot
of the team basically since Microsoft
was really heavy into the development to
the Xbox but hadn't finalized any other
designs as soon as Sega went under
apparently they literally just had
poachers just walk in there and start
like being like hi who wants an
application apply so a lot of the people
who designed the controller who designed
the idea of V abuse a lot of those
people came over and that's why I think
Xbox managed to fix a lot of the
problems the Dreamcast had they're like
okay it has to have a DVD player it has
to have a cable modem built in and needs
a built-in hard drive right away like
they definitely were like okay let's
skip the small pitfalls the Dreamcast
hats we don't make the same mistake
twice that's actually a valid point
because uh back during the Dreamcast era
that was the issue like the modem was
separate right which was kind of cool
what what did they call it the memory
card it memory you know child refresh my
memory was like would that they had like
separate games only the most to tell you
just like enhancements to existing Tyler
Sonic Adventure because you were able to
take your little guys with you and raise
them in your pockets like Tamagotchi so
it was their version because Tamagotchi
was blowing up so big and they said if
we can get something like that on a go
and have a visual unit in the front
which I thought Microsoft was gonna try
to do when they put the you know the X
in the middle and it was gigantic on
odoo controller which they're doing
actually now um but I love the vmu for
the fact that it popped out and when I
went to your house I put my vmu in your
controller of my control scheme ahead of
his time oh hell yeah who's the best it
has three cross-platform games and the
best version will be on Dreamcast like
I'm obsessed with Resident Evil and I
always had to play everything
on the Dreamcast because when you look
to your controller it's say the amount
of bullets you had less in your clip no
like in those early games the only way
to see that was deposit so only on the
Dreamcast could I see okay I got three
more shots before I'm gonna have to
reload so I gotta run have memories with
that stuff to me oh it's the
heartstrings the feelings man shut up
the pita wallet man I mean they were so
aggressive during that time I felt that
was supposed to be the what like that's
just it was supposed to be the one for
them you know
that's cool bit so movin know once I
didn't you said you got on the Xbox you
got that going and stuff like that and
now obviously the Xbox the original Xbox
success wasn't as long last so you know
we have the PlayStation come up next did
you didn't transition to that like what
was the next evolution for you I got a
PlayStation 2 late in the console
generation just for the RPGs I don't
wear the thing where I ended up buying
Final Fantasy 10 four separate times
because I kept having PlayStation 2s
broken there was a time where I bought I
bought I finally saved up and I bought
it in his home broke into my house and
stole it when I was about halfway
through the game so I just basically
quit at a certain point where it's like
okay look like the gaming Lords do not
want me to have the lowest is not meant
to be like I am fully willing to admit
that that's just not in my card so I
didn't really get into ps2 until much
later now I have hundreds of ps2 games
but at the time I I just started going
from Xbox 2 Xbox 360 a lot of people did
say that so tough so pretty much now
just real quick ranking like obviously
no dreamcast is up there
so what overall was your second favorite
system I probably put the ps4 really
near the top I know it sounds crazy
because because it's currently going on
but we're just in an age now like such
an indie revolution it's cool that I own
202 ps4 games which sounds crazy but so
much that are like I'm I love twin-stick
shooters I love puzzle games I love
really big open world stuff I've gotten
into racing games as I've gotten older
and all of that is incredibly awesome in
50 different flavours on my playstation
4 that's something I've never seen
before
nice and last question far as gaming is
concerned I'm I'm gonna do something new
with the gesso I want you to give me
like some of your top 5 games of all
time if you could narrow it down to 5 of
all time totally off the top of my head
I would say led you to Zelda Ocarina of
Time skies money media on the Dreamcast
version of Skies of Arcadia the best I'd
say and this could be a controversial
one but I'd probably say Alan Wake on
the xbox360 I think that is one of the
best horror games as cliche as it is
it's [ __ ] awesome if you get the DLC
it's oh I don't know I think it keeps
going I really really love uh let's see
Silent Hill 2 I would say is one of the
best let me think for my fifth one oh
gosh I'd say Final Fantasy 7 yes okay
no doubt all right so then we got that
going on so let's talk about the start
of the whole keep dreaming movement in
that amazing channel that you have like
when did that start for you I'm a way
way back I first started the channel and
I made my first videos in like 2008 and
then I I put it down for like many many
years but originally I saw the Angry
Video Game Nerd videos and I've always
been a type of person of like when I see
something cool I want to make it like if
I read a cool book I want to write a
cool book so when I watched the Angry
Video Game Nerd videos I immediately
went I could make that and so I actually
ended up making several Dreamcast
reviews that were very angry video game
nerd in style like I just tried to
emulate his writing and I think
basically I did this I didn't understand
what a capture card was so my first
videos I literally set up a webcam aimed
at my TV and it was perfectly set up so
that it would be like the dimensions of
it so kind of will say capture card
until like bright colors would show up
and then the auto like the auto filter
would screw up but I just basically play
the game and then edit the footage and
the really like dumb voice over and then
have like cutaways of me be like you
excuse me will I interrupt my own video
and make fun of this week it was
basically just Dreamcast guy tries to be
angry video game nerd very badly did as
you as you progressed what made you like
stick waited and continued to continue
on well I put it down for a long time
because I ended up just losing my job
and roaming for about five years and
then I picked it back up and 2013 I just
randomly started watching a bunch of
YouTube videos and I saw just for a
video this is the first time I'd ever
seen somebody just sit down in front of
a collection and talk for like ten
minutes and it was so interesting but
more than that it was so simple it was
the first time it just like smack me in
the face of like oh it's just whatever
like anybody can be a youtuber that's
the best part of this website is
literally like just sit down on camera
and if you have something fun to say
with more passion than your rivals you
will get views and so I just started
doing rants and then I started
experimenting because I've always liked
writing so I experimented with writing
reviews and it just it just snowballed
over the course last couple years now
the next question you always want to
know this is a keep dreaming the slogan
when did you start what influenced me
it's my first video ever all the way the
beginning I just needed a catchphrase I
literally didn't have any idea what's
funny is the first mean comments I ever
got in 2008 is preservative my first
video I'm wearing a fedora because I
thought that was so cool the lighting is
really bad and so the scarring of my
face looked even worse at the spin I
would keep dreaming and the first mean
calm and I ever get said I bet you want
to keep dreaming you Freddy Krueger
looking [ __ ]
alright I deserve that that's a good one
better lighting I got you bro everybody
loves you it's just that positive energy
you have and you know everything just
rubs every screen you're scanning just a
cool channel to watch I came across
again shout out the Lord out of he know
he couldn't make he's he's hurting that
he couldn't be infinite because he's
also a fan he doesn't he introduced me
you know overall TT channel but I was
just
I going through your vids and I'm like I
love this guy's guy's hilarious babies
this is great great energy you know
shout out the Lord Megatron you got
people in a chat right now who's saying
they just coming across your channel he
just subscribed to you super thumbs up
and we love what you do it out here
that's cool it's so fun like that's the
craziest thing of all like obviously
since this is my job there are some
times where I'm up till like 3:00 a.m.
editing and I'm tired but for the most
part it is just so damn fun like it's
like my job very much is talking about
video games I get like I've literally
about I just been playing Mario honestly
all weekend and I'm reading a script
about Mario Odyssey it's just like me
and this is what pays my freakin bills
like I'm such a very lucky dude
how cool is that in your mentality it
all comes across you know again we
appreciate you man
so we gonna get into a what the Lords
are playing this week obviously it's a
big gaming week so start off with my
Dreamcast I know you said Odyssey
anything else you this week yeah I beat
Wolfenstein too because I got
Wolfenstein to normal days early and
holy gosh Wolfenstein is a freaking
masterpiece it is so okay
okay can't wait till we go we gonna get
it to them over to the segments that
that's cool I'm glad you saying my
confidence that's awesome have you been
playing this week it's your trust
logic just so you know we planning on we
saw almost on a panel planning on
getting the X and we kind of had like a
pact that we're gonna wait to November
7th to play - yeah it's hard
[Laughter]
it's about conditioning your mind
they're not actually there for ya I mean
from Mario Mario's been keeping me kind
of busy man Mario is just this fantastic
no I know we'll talk more about it a
little bit talk about more about the
murderers row sue Lloyd King whatever
playing sweet destiny I'm just heart and
a lot of things
I'm just heartened at the fact that
people are running around with this
rhetoric
if you say something long enough people
start to believe it and once people
starts to believe the rhetoric then they
start to act on the rhetoric and it's a
lot of rhetoric thrown around talking
about destiny is dead destiny is not
dead there's a lot of things you're
doing destiny um I know a couple of
people that are in a couple of clans I
won't mention that at this day and age
are at 265 I had to go in there and work
with people's clan mates to get them up
I don't like the fact that you know my
own clan the leader is you know it's
just a filter down within the clan mates
I play every day I take prestige night
falls we do raids we do everything you
know hone your skills I'm supposed to
pick up Mario today and I'm gonna pick
it up and I want the physical copy of it
oh I really want the physical of it
because I have all like the Mario
galaxy's physicals it's just something
about looking over at just a collective
standpoint that physical and Lords what
I know it's been I know your topic later
will be that a destined to PC but uh
besides that bat has there anything else
um you've been playing this with be
honest I've been it's been kind of light
for me because
I kind of took a step back from games
and I'm learning how to code like Java
Python Ruby and trying to try to kind of
build up another technical aspect and
things about a technical game and watch
it takes off but yeah I've been playing
destiny too in the PC primarily for the
past week and I also picked up poking
torment just out of curiosity and I
actually do find that pretty fun as well
nice so you know you didn't you stay
away from the goddess II switch because
I know your switch game like this so
stay wait oh just waiting I just
happened I just haven't made my way out
I'm I'm with David I gotta I gotta have
that that physical copy of that physical
any amiibos in there oh by the way I'm
jealous
crazy jealous I saw your moves and I'm
crazy jealous right now I got the
feeling in my chest and it's burning me
if you had a little sit there like oh my
god I gotta get to the story I mean it's
been it's been tough meet just murderers
row week as we know October 27th was
that uh touch the goddess II a little
bit this week and yeah man I was just
you know we'll get into it but I've been
having some fun with that but
surprisingly there's still this little
indie game on the Nintendo eShop this is
the police has my mind wrapped I am in
love this game oh it again it's a lot of
simulation and these sorts management
kind of like on XCOM style but you're
managing personalities you know it has
some of the best writing ever I believe
though the voice actors from Duke Nukem
and I'm telling y'all right now this
game pushes social ed morality
boundaries they test you let's just say
that like I'll be just not to spoil too
much but it was like you know I played
soon as the game started you know City
Hall was like it's riots in the street
race wives is this going on I need you
to fire or you're you know
african-american officers I'll tell you
right now like it's it's not only 12
written it's funny and you get
emotionally invested I believe right now
it's been on Xbox one and ps4 for a
while it just came to the Nintendo eShop
it isn't it's amateur rated game
shoutout to Nintendo for even allowing
this content on the platform good to me
that shows maturity like a game like
this can be on it but if you have I know
it's murderers row weak but you know
maybe if it's on sale down the road pick
up this is the police this game believe
it's weapon game studios shout out to
them they hit me back on Twitter I am in
love with this thing I cannot stop
playing this game yes anchorman identify
that older lady officer she came to work
she had to go I'm sorry like do you want
to fire her legally lorca Beto's twitter
or my check check my timeline I've got a
lot of screenshots of this game and I
get emotionally invested like it's
clarity
check out what to the line your bug out
so that's what I've been rockin Oh
quickly quickly just actively with a guy
Wolverine
you've been talking you've been talking
about it for the past few weeks if you
are an old-school gamer that's into
Streets of Rage shinobi any of these
side scrolling like beat-em-ups shmups
this is a game for you i it took me a
couple of weeks before i really fell
into what kognito was talking about but
honestly it's a beautiful game it's
bloody as hell um it's just honestly
like it just scratches that itch of
those old-school side-scrolling beat'em
ups like if you you're a fan of Guardian
heroes a Streets of Rage get this game
fantastic it is really good but no those
guys I'll be all I need from it if they
could come somehow come up with like an
oil eye patch that's all that's missing
from it because it had coop it has local
co-op but it's really good
got the blade I'm gonna keep digging you
guys up I believe Illustrated knows
Michael held in those guys that is a
master please and and the voice acting
and and just the cinematics like they've
really made a production out of a twenty
dollar game and or guys yeah you guys
need to check it out Wolverine
salute so let's get into the show we got
a lot to discuss but um we had a poll
last week so the poll results are in and
the people have spoken to the question
if serious allegations
aka ethical sexual were made against a
publisher or developer of your favorite
video game franchise would you honestly
not purchase the game in ylp polls ever
is the know this won't stop me for by
the game group I'm truly surprised that
the numbers is that close I mean coming
in that second at only 25 percent was
the yes I can't support that game and
neither should you group and hilariously
cuz removers three choices coming right
21 percent very close third place was
but how serious allegations I wanna
bring it to the round table what do the
Lords think about this let's I would
love you can I think it depends on the
level of the offense so my thing is like
if it turns out that that like yeah I'm
sure you guys heard the head of Ober
like this dude was like basically hiring
like you would hire and surround himself
with just like attractive women and then
just basically be like alright blow me
or you're fired like he was a piece
sounds like this is the police as long
as he was at the company I wouldn't use
uber just go suture it's like I don't
want to give any money that I know is
gonna go out of that dude's pocket
today's gonna basically like abuse
people with so I've like I love rockstar
games I love Square Enix I'm a big like
Final Fantasy addict and if I found out
like somebody if Square Enix was just
being crazy crazy I think I'd have a
issue it as much as I love final fantasy
I'd buy a used copy to make sure they
didn't get my profit or something like
if we're talking like a a low-level
employees like Patton asses or something
I'm not gonna punish 200 people on his
team right what you just said was what
with the consensus on the island podcast
Twitter shout out to everyone competing
because that's what they was saying they
would like look you know obviously
depends on the offense but it's kind of
what you say like this the mentality was
like I'm if one person you had one bad
apple who did something I'm not gonna
allow that to affect the purchases you
know the work of the majority of the
group it kind of repeated what you just
said Oh Jim gasps was some stuff going
on and you know what I said to myself
with that header where you got that
stuff that's nice for you that doesn't
have anything to do with the uber
drivers picking me up right now you
could be the face of the company ha ha
that's your business
it's other employees that have
absolutely nothing to do with that tom
has to pay his mortgage and trust me Tom
I got you I'm buying that game 100% I
don't care that he was doing organ donor
organ organs on the black market
- I didn't even know is the option I
could buy you I'll betray the end so
make sure you stay tuned for that so we
gonna get into these topics show right
so I'll start up first at the rent table
it was a great week of gaming this week
is what I'm affectionate Lee called the
murder is wrong of October 27th it is
hit so would it bring this to the Lord I
was leading Muriel Odyssey aka Mary oh
god I see had Assassin's Creed origins
you know and of course thanks to Lord
Dreamcast is amazing impressions video
and anchorman V shot anchorman V on his
Twitter you know for basically giving
some non spoilery impressions of that
Wolfenstein to do Colossus so what I'm
gonna bring it to a low Dreamcast first
since he's our guest arm out of the
three
have you played each of the three and if
you have the ones that you have played
of the murderers row on what not just
with some basic impressions you know
early spoiler free of course yeah I
haven't played Assassin's Creed origins
but I'm going to I actually I have
Assassin's Creed origins sitting on my
desk right now installing on the ps4 I
have beaten both Mario Odyssey and
Wolfenstein and they're both really good
um
I guess I want to start with Mario
Odyssey and say it's incredibly
surprising like it seems like it may
have been done by a different team
there's so many subtle touches that are
so different like like they'll show
Bowser and Bowser will like get hit in
the face with like a shell and it'll
zoom in on his hand and his hand will
like twitch there's like there's a lot
of subtle animation differences the
world structures different Mario even
runs at a different speed that what
we're used to so I liked just being so
caught off guard by Mario again it
really
like the first time you picked up
mario64 like what the hell is this what
are these world's what is this new Cappy
ability so I have to say gameplay is
revolutionized in all the ways I didn't
know I wanted nice it's no what about
now no you did your Wolfenstein let's go
right into that now what you've been
raving is hell yeah is it worth the
price of admission for anybody that was
one offense or guy who never really
played the Wolfenstein games like that
how to prevent I I will put my
reputation on the line that this game is
is going to be remembered I think as
much as its it's as good or nearly as
good as something like Bioshock it's one
of those games that tells you a story
you didn't you you didn't see coming it
really goes in to the backstory of a guy
who's willing to die fighting Nazis like
not that BG Wiseman's dies but but they
really go into his past and show
sections of his childhood and tell why
he wanted to join in the fight for
America against the Nazis even though at
this point Nazis are walking around in
giant robots and shooting lasers he was
willing to pick up a crappy little
pistol and fight just because some
people would rather die doing something
good then be happy doing something bad
you know and let's not forget the fact
that you get to shoot the hell out of
Nazis there's a nuclear but I love the
the marketing that potestas doing oh
well Machine Studios what are they doing
for it it's like they like this is not
to keep living like these are not good
people like who's doing Wolfenstein 2 is
amazing but continue so on that topic
did you see there they vie snoozed in an
interview with Pete Hines the head of
marketing for Bethesda and they asked
him like don't you think that you're
actually poking the hornet's nest a bit
by really trying to stir up the Nazis
and Pete Hines goes well we believe we
may be poking the hornet's nest but it's
a hornet's nest full of Nazis and [ __ ]
Nazis really go for it in pushing the
boundaries so yet that things looking
good you know I'm trying to stay strong
we live for the Xbox with X version but
I'm hearing so many great things and now
let me ask you about the third game
murderers row which was that Assassin's
Creed origins have you got a chance to
touch it at all not I I can't as well as
these were work wise I can't start
playing it until I finish my script for
Mario Odyssey just cuz I'm sure this is
gonna start to it's gonna seep into my
brain I'm gonna start being like a
climbing this is great but climbing in
Assassin's Creed let's make that
comparison so I I can't turn it on for a
couple more hours but then as soon as I
do my plan is actually to play it for
like 10 hours today and do at least an
impressions video for tomorrow so I'm
definitely to be doing all day with
Assassin's Creed let's not serve wrong
out of the three did you well to we know
don't exist for you that's that Xbox for
the next premium talk well as far as the
goddess I know that's what you've been
rocking so uh talk to us spoiler free
impressions I think it's just it's
amazing I it's one of the few games that
I just I can recall just I stopped and I
and I catch myself smiling while I'm
playing it because it's just like it's
just delightful it didn't at every
corner honestly they've taken what's
best about Mario and 3d and they've just
blown it out completely they're taking
the best aspects of Mario over the years
and they've given you a little bit of
that in this game without me they making
it very accessible it's not as hard a
game as as past Mario 3d Mario games um
something that uh Lord Dreamcast said
that um yeah graphically the game for
what it is so crisp and it just the way
it feels and it's like a lot of the
worlds aren't necessarily heavily
populated but they are sort of dense but
then you see little things like like in
the desert state you see god rays coming
through and stuff like that like it's a
very pretty game mm-hmm and to be honest
like I in the past I love Mario but I've
always fallen off because for whatever
reason like it's just it becomes a
little too daunting they're too many
stars to collect the what
like you know I've always fallen off but
now I'm all the way in I'm trying to get
as many moons as I can before I move on
to the next world
honestly yeah man like as of right now
and I'm a big wolfenstein head and I'm a
big Assassin's Creed head it's right up
there 1 & 2 for the year for me between
that zelda between for me doing that in
Zelda and I might give the edge to Zelda
overall because that's more my type of
game and the friends I got from playing
Zelda but to me Zelda moved move kind of
move things in a different direction
that I complete but a Mario Mario is you
gotta remember Mario invented the wheel
when it comes to platforming in 2d and
3d so it Miata see is a continued
refinement of that wheel like they just
said right they just continue to improve
the formula that they perfected honestly
no one's ever touched them so but it's
it's fantastic it did there's there's no
losers here no doubt so we always bend
me to marry oh for paving the way for us
though so uh Lord King I know you two
games are the murderers row don't exist
for you as well I know you're waiting so
my question to you is out of the three
murderers row what's the game you're
most excited to play first about to
realize what your vision truly is
Assassin's Creed looks like the
combination of all their hard work and
this is the I know it's not over film
but it seems like this is their end game
this is what they were building to
and the combat system from what I
touched was fantastic the graphics we
already know it was top-notch they're
scrambling the moving the interactions
with the NPC's in the city it looked
beautiful I didn't get a chance to hear
it I didn't get a chance to hit a
fidelity and it shout out the
Plantronics for giving me these great
headsets and Adobe Atmos that listening
to that game with the graphic fidelity
the headphones sick but as far as mario
goes which i'll be picking up today and
i'm gonna play today because other games
but I look forward to Mario and just
like Lord sovereign said it's not a
reinvention of the wheel
it's a refinement of the wheel they just
gave you tires on this little buggy
wheel that they've been building and no
one has been able to touch him like he
said they are the pioneers in 2d
platforming which was phenomenal can't
touch them their people are still doing
speedruns and regular Mario come on look
at this crazy right crazy then like from
sunshine to galaxy to Odyssey it's they
are doing their thing and I wish they
can get some of that magic on a sonic I
really wish they can sprinkle that on a
signer because we got the 2d sonic down
pack this 2d something just came out cuz
I'm scared to buy the this what is this
squadron supreme sonic let's go talk to
us about that oh man so if you Japanese
switch account you can actually download
a demo and it is the worst demo I've
ever played
it's yeah you basically you have access
to three different levels a like a 3d
level a 2d level in a boss level but you
can only play each level for 60 seconds
to the second this time reverse and what
sucks is like the levels are really not
well designed they're very clunky
there's lots of like little tiny
lipstick you'll be running along at 200
miles an hour like yeah this is true
sonic speed and you just touch like a
bush dead stop instantly like oh okay
cool and so you have to get your speed
up again and so that timer just kills
you man and so it's like eat eat without
the timer in the full game I just it
looks really bad like I played that uh
[ __ ] for an hour try try to each demo
like several times trying to like trying
to like it and man I know I got my
roommate to play he like came in my
office let me go check this out and he
played it any like literally stone-faced
place the 60 seconds so he's like
alright why did you even install this
it's not even a game real quick looking
for Munoz I want to know what you're
feeling zone
Wolfenstein I've heard you talk about it
so the sucks the game is fantastic right
but the only way I could take a shot at
the game is them you know adding some
aftermath stuff you guys think we're
gonna get some DLC for Mario yeah I can
see it coming like why not take more
lives I have a feeling cuz I actually
found like a Mario 64 painting
at the bottom of one level like in one
of the water levels and I went through
it and it took you to another world so I
have a feeling that they're gonna do
something where there's gonna be like a
Mario 64 style DLC level I have a
feeling that they they have so much of
the the pieces of these other games I
think that they could straight-up like
all right this is the Mario Galaxy DLC
level and people like me would like
Hello here's my wallet opportunity for
them to do something like that it to me
be silly and until your point earlier
laundry cast when you were saying about
the UM the the way it feels I heard that
my amato didn't do this one that it was
another person as far as II on the
development aspect with it in
conjunction with that actually had more
of a hands-on approach cuz we're getting
different little nuances and stuff that
I've really never seen you know it was
the the biggest thing is man the whole
cap you think taking over in aids yeah
holy like two main enemies on each world
basically you can take over and man that
just blew my mind like isn't one of my
favorite ones is there's this thing it
looks like it's like a centipede type
dude he's like a big yellow like
cartoonish like caterpillar and when you
take him over you have stretch out like
an accordion and you can actually
stretch out over cliffs having to
basically extend you're walking along
like cliff faces and over like lava gaps
and stuff like crazy jumps that Mario
could never make and and every time he
extends it actually makes an accordion
noise so it's like so funny and it's so
cute and it's so different than what I
was expecting it's just like holy [ __ ]
like this is the game I didn't know I
freaking wanted facts about it again to
you when I jump in real quick oh when I
got just the beginning like when I got a
control of the dinosaur and like they
put epic music when you have it makes
you wanna destroy stuff it makes you I
got so it took like control that is kind
of funny but do it over the little SWAT
right quick out of obviously he's been
doing his destiny to thing he's got a
topic in that but I'm out of the three
murderers role which is the ones that
have you the most excited well right now
I have to say Wolfenstein to actually
sounds really good
we're saying I could go send like a lot
of fun but I'm I think it would be with
Lord King and have to run out really
quick after this and go pick up Mary
Odyssey gotta see you gotta pick it up
for me I just wrapped it up real quick
all three men look fantastic you know I
play like I said to Mario and like to
Lord sovereigns point just to feel I
think when I play that game I can't stop
smiling it's with like the game just
makes you laugh it makes you smile it's
all the nostalgic feels of um of Mario
and just one thing I really impressed me
was how graphically it looks you know I
played know Charlie and Yan Italy you
know in Doc I mean not an undocumented
more when I was at work and then when I
brought it home and look fantastic there
just the reflection is the water going
off your skin or stuff and then like I
brought her home that I seen the jump in
docked and I'm like doesn't get enough
credit for how graphically good it looks
you know it looks good and um so I've
been having fun with that Assassin's
Creed is an emotional thing for me like
Lord Kings saying it's like I'm a huge
fan of just that whole time peace
you know Egyptian the pyramids that
whole bit so I can't wait to dive into
that it's kind of because I'm waiting on
the Xbox one next version because I'm a
consular guy so just just trying to hold
on November 7th but I was very tempted
it's sitting on my hard drive and again
Wolfenstein I mean I didn't expect I
would pick this game up
but again launching catch your video I
mean put me over the edge
um lord anchorman his tweet I'm seeing a
lot of positive stuff and then the other
thing is because I'm waiting for the
Xbox when that's another reason why I'm
really holding out for Wolfenstein is
from my understanding that is going to
be 4k 6000 I can see that in its glory
man
there there is a scene that is gonna
melt your brain where at one point you
literally have to climb on top of a
train that is rocketing through an
underground tunnel and you're fighting
robot Nazis inside there with shotguns
and so that at 1080p 60 frames a second
you're literally gonna be crying blood
and people already said like you said it
looks that now I can't even imagine what
for Kasich so that's gonna be well yeah
yeah that's gonna be like my showcase
game for when I get the exit that I'm
purposely holding on to a lot of titles
and Xbox where you can hang stuff for
that purpose to showcase on that game in
that system so and I got my 4k setup
ready so I'm ready to go you know via
photo murderers Rover this is a great
time for gaming we talked about this a
lot and it's here and we even got
stranger things knowing our life was
good right
thus we gonna move on to this next topic
I wanna get this over to our Lord
sovereign so uh got some publisher
issues uh
sámi act Capcom what's going on out here
man
alright yeah so it's good that we have
Jim Cass here because it's something
about insomniac and Capcom that they
traditionally have made games that have
been a little on the quirky side and to
me that that goes right in line with
what
Seigo used to be right when you had a
Sega console you had Sega games there
was something you always had your art
arcade ports for like and that those
those were fantastic and perfect but
then they were always willing to take
the risks on these smaller quirky type
of titles and it was always it was
something that kind of identified Sega's
identity to me it's being willing to do
that and these are two companies that
have titles that sort of kind of can
mention two that sort of ideology and so
for me going into the the insomniac
stuff which sunset overdrive sunset
overdrive was an xbox one exclusive that
by all accounts didn't do as well as
they had Microsoft had hoped it would do
a lot of people thought that it was a
game that didn't necessarily mesh well
with what you know what Xbox is and
probably would have felt better on
another system I love the game I know a
lot of the Lords picked it up at launch
if not afterwards I know a lot of people
played it once it came to games with
gold it's it's a very unique game they
kind of harkens back to again a Sega
game like Jet Set Radio moons and grime
radio it goes back to that
sort of stuff the mobility um and it's
just something that I felt was
underappreciated on a platform that
tends to get looked at as you know the
shooter platform or something like that
so my feeling is that they're shopping
around for a publisher to get a sequel
done and Microsoft has been mum on it
and it's disappointing to me because to
me I think this is a point where
Microsoft needs to continue to
differentiate their portfolio and kind
of expand what what it means to be a
Microsoft game you know me and kind of
expand their identity and the fact that
we've gone into this in the past how
they're just not willing to take second
chances on properties that didn't do as
well as they had hoped and I think it's
a sad thing I mean it'd be great for it
to go multi-platinum Stu play this
series be fantastic but I think it's an
opportunity missed for them if they
don't hop into that so that's that's one
and then we go into the Capcom thing
with a rumours that they're in dire
straits and yes they're looking to be
bought out and this is this is huge if
this is actually true because I mean
it's not like we're looking at a THQ
fire sale which is you know they had
some great properties but it's not
Capcom when you say you're breaking up
Capcom everybody's I should to open wide
and salad salivating at the mouth to
pick up some property check out Lord
Dreamcast is video on Capcom - a lot of
deals there yeah yeah so honestly I mean
this is another opportunity I think for
everybody but especially Microsoft this
sort of hurting for for properties to
sort of consider what would fit best on
the Xbox platform these guys have
against some of the best of the best
over the years and they have a lot of a
lot of properties that haven't really
been used lately they have Megaman they
have I don't know how many different
versions of res evil Onimusha there's
something that people have been
screaming to come back so there there's
a lot of properties there that can be
done justice and talking about a
dreamcast video and how they
certain games that yeah I think they've
gone to the well a little too often with
certain with certain properties and they
the ideas in them have been can become
stagnated to the point where even the
hard core kind of going away from them
you saw this which Street Fighter 5
where they gave you a bare-bones game
and the professional players stuck to it
because yeah that's this is what they're
gonna play but the casuals who loved it
kind of like where's the rest of the
game and when they gave you the rest of
the game the quality was so far below
even what you expect from you know from
a fighting game story mode that it just
it kind of fell off the same name with
more Wars Capcom infinite infinite by
all accounts is a great game fighting
wise but the decision to go with the the
art style that they went with the fact
that they're not having these classic
characters that people are so used to
having in new games at least at this
point not in the game is something again
that's it's kind of dropping people
interest in this game I just want to
jump in on that one part of infinite I
actually played out if you look
yesterday I was on playing it last night
um that's a Disney thing it's not really
have comp thing um if you know what
Disney is trying to do as far as killing
Fox oh yeah they kill it yes Meneer
right they killed all of the mutants in
the comic books on purpose um to to hurt
Fox's brand because if x-men is
successful in the books in any in any
other places then the movies will be
successful and its strategic and it's
smart you devalue the property you pick
the property up and then you build it
back up same thing with the Fantastic
Four they did that on my own
um but the game is really good story
mode is really good
it's way better than the Street Fighter
I have the Street Fighter it's stone
cold is disgusting um but it's ice cold
it's ice cold it was cold it was DOA on
arrival and it did not resuscitate when
it's doing
send the DLC through I don't care how
many free things you send through if
your initial impression of a game is of
such it's going to stay that way but
back to the infinite give it a shot
if you can you know play a demo go to
somebody's house share the game the
story mode really surprised me and it
was it was better than all of their
other story modes in the Capcom games I
really didn't think they had any they
would just go fight here fight fight now
but this one actually has a cohesive
story that goes and spreads across many
hours it's also super cheesy I mean I
for I forever live mess there's a moment
where I straight straight up Ryu walks
out of an Egyptian pyramid and says me
and my research team we're actually
doing some seismic studies to make sure
that the lords is what do you guys think
about this if Microsoft making mistake
by at least giving sunset overdrive to a
chance to thrive on its system and what
do you think of the Calphalon stuff if
that is the case should they should they
hop on that stuff and what should they
hop on it I guess going looking cast
going haha I think you bring up a
freakin extremely smart point which is
that if Microsoft does step in and at
least buy a couple Capcom properties if
the rumors are true they could
capitalize that major like seriously if
they just came up and said hey do you
want to see the first ever Western
developed Megaman let's make Mega Man
Legends 3 you guys been begging it'll be
a giant open-world third-person shooter
but with the still cartoony graphics you
guys like we're not gonna make it gritty
and weird it's not going to be Gears of
Mega Man that could be a huge marketing
push in and that would be extremely
valuable but what more realistically
what I think is gonna happen is before
it even goes publicly on market I bet
they'll probably sell like Mega Man and
stuff to Nintendo and then they'll open
up the market and sell off like Onimusha
to Sony and stuff and I think they'll
probably keep a couple properties that
stay profitable I think I think Capcom
will always own Resident Evil for
example but I knew they're gonna be a
picked apart mm-hmm yeah yeah Megatron
in the chair he's gonna cost me with ten
price at e3 Wow yeah man I mean I'm with
you Lord Dreamcast because it's like I
mean the sunset overdrive thing is very
it's a weird one for me because you know
I see what you check out the walkabouts
we tried it didn't the first one didn't
resonate with me and I shouted oppressed
our podcast guys we talked about this
this week on Sunday so check them out
great great Google gamers had a lot of
fun on that show um basically we talked
about is that like for example I
understand the importance of the game
like sunset overdrive for Xbox because
you know as far as I'm concerned you
know I've complained many times I call
you know Microsoft some time to shoot a
box and they fall into that you know rut
of Big Mac large fries and shake with
gears force and Halo right we know those
are successful but a title like sunset
overdrive those are get different type
of gamers onto the platform and I think
it's important now of all first title
did not resonate with me specifically I
understand its uniqueness I understand
how important that is to the ecosystem
right and you can get when you get a
game like that that's different that
people love just for that type of genre
sometimes they're on your platform like
oh by the way you guys got kids all
right let me check this out you know the
older type of game that kind of they
don't necessarily have to be home runs
offered to jump you know but they kind
of bring other gamers in the second
point to it which has been really
frustrated with the insomnia situation
is sunset overdrive is that you know
we've talked about this at nauseam loss
all we know is like Microsoft has this
tendency that when they do put out a new
IP that they buy like a rise or whatever
you know because it doesn't it's not a
financial success out of the jump they
tend to fall away from and there's no
sequel whereas you have Sony where I
mean for God's sake there's an act
out right now you know nak got a sequel
but we don't okay I deal with the mark
sorry I know you I was a launch game in
a lineup it's so directly true true but
did this distance isn't Sony you know
where they've had titles that no again
we're not commercial successes with the
first iteration but they stuck with the
franchise reinvest listen to what the
the feedback of that the community is
that's what I want to see which was of
them to me it's pathetic that insomniac
is on Twitter he begging for a publisher
like to me like when I can sort of fill
get on the phone like come on like there
could be ton of stuff they can do it
that's just me or not as far as the
Capcom thing you know with large Inc has
to saying is that you know watch this
video and it just it's really sad to see
them in this and they've made so many
mistakes you know and it's just crazy
because like they had this tremendous
history I mean we all grow up a Capcom
right we've all these iconic franchises
you know and it's pretty scary for me to
hear about I'm going away a world
without no Capcom that would be kind of
scary and I want to bring it back to the
Lord instead around table as far as you
know I know our logic has mentioned
Microsoft um how would you guys feel if
either Nintendo or Sony jumped in like
who do we feel it may be the best
candidates if if these rumors are true
okay well this this is how I feel about
it as far as the Capcom thing goes for
you it's good for you because you sat
there you took us for granted good for
you because you did now put your best
foot forward at all times good for you
good for you because you are watered
down a lot of IPs and you didn't do like
Nintendo does Nintendo nurtures and hoes
their properties and they won't put it
out until they feel it's the absolute
best um and sometimes if they look at a
vision and it's going the wrong way
the reassessed a vision and they put the
games off for a period of time but
you're gonna get a game
they're not gonna water it down they
could
a million mario games that year but not
one of those games awarded down um so
they did that but in the same vein you
got a look at Neo Geo and you gotta say
well Neo Geo did the same thing I'm
looking Neo Geo's fate right so I can't
sit here and say I'm feel sorry for
Calculon I don't um no III don't because
there's going to be life after this and
maybe they can rise up like the Phoenix
from the ashes but like Lord Jim cats
guy said I don't believe they're gonna
get rid of resin evil at all because the
movie franchises no matter what you
think sells it sells Rockets right so
they're gonna keep that property alright
so that's money in the bank they're
there they can sell off something like
Megaman Megaman fits Nintendo's mold
like he said I think there's no close
auction to Nintendo first or certain IPS
that fit the Nintendo ecosystem my
Megaman is one of them okay so that goes
there then you say some of the Japanese
properties this is where I don't think
Microsoft fits in at all alright um
because you say you look at the Japanese
properties you look at how many motion
you look at other stuff like the resume
was off the table so Omni motion would
actually go to Sony because Denny
debuted on a sunny system in my opinion
yeah this is what I think they even
helped with publishing so I think they
can look we've done this song and dance
here's a million thank you all take it
back
thank you so much as ours you know this
belongs here anyway so if it's there
what's left for Microsoft basically that
will be something that they will say
okay yeah we give you X amount of bucks
for this it's not a super seller it has
its cult following like you know super
b-movie oh and it fit their type of
thing but in Microsoft's new philosophy
do they go forward buying stuff is that
happen for Microsoft and I don't believe
as much faith as I got in film I don't
believe that fits inside Phil's
philosophy the mold catch right so then
so then who do you think Lord cannot
bring it back
to you who do you think is the best
candidate only okay is although it's
coming out for everybody it's being
pushed and shown on the ps4 so because
of the install base oh yeah in fact is
in I was gonna say keep in mind that
there is probably some behind the scenes
bad blood between Capcom and Sony
because I was reading a report that
basically said that they wanted to cook
Street Fighter 5 for another six months
but Sony's since they were paying their
bills while they develop it forced him
to release it in that really unfinished
State they apparently the internal memo
was we need this out three full months
before Evo you need to have people
playing this and interested in this
suing a ten million dollar tournaments
for this so basically even though Capcom
was like we know this is not done we
literally have like drawings for the
cutscenes this is not done apparently
Sony walked in there and said well
that's a goddamn shame I'm paying your
rent and it's going on storoe moving
over it's interesting you say that
because I do remember the Ock I said it
was a huge uproar in the fighting
community because of its unfinished
state but it's like you said I do
remember the evil that time frame yes
what and and it was really weird it was
very behind closed doors they weren't
open staged events it was very much like
a camera crew in like a so who's a very
controlled very very weird it might lend
credence to what you're saying here that
you know Sony pushed pushed and it
wasn't the money back then I'm surprised
that that never went more time flat I
must admit I wasn't eventually like it
would be like a super
she'd find a deluxe Alfa sony Sony
bought the right Sony bought the rights
to Street Fighter 5 and bought
exclusivity and they said okay you're
allowed to release it on PC but it can
never go to an Xbox platform ever so
because the wording of that contract we
may see a Street Fighter 5 ultimate
Kamehameha Edition on stage I don't
think it can ever legally exist on an
Xbox console until that contract expires
Wow makes sense
it makes sense let's get lost while he's
been quietly chance to get his feelings
on all this news about insomniac and you
know it sunset overdrive too and and you
know possible rumors demise of Capcom
wait what do you stand with this was
what it's a lot to take in I really
didn't look too much since the details
of this but hearing from you guys it
sounds like it's it's a real nightmare
for a lot of different a lot of
different people but um you know I'm a
big fan of the Resident Evil series and
doesn't evil ya think that there might
not be another one that kind of hurts
but at the same time I know that there
would be someone that would grab that
mantle that's such a big such a big
series as you said I mean they could
even keep that and hold that as one of
their only IPs and they could probably
still do well I think I think that maybe
what what could transpire with a lot of
things that you guys talked about it is
there might be a lot of a lot of
different developers that might pick up
the the intellectual property isn't
actually run them in and actually do
something that's the fans love because
you never really know I mean it's a lot
like I mean sonic would say I mean I
wish Sega would just release like it
just like let somebody else be careful
you can Sonic and I love sonic
adventures but the sonic go six post
Sonic of six it was terrible it's been
terrible so it's just on the note I
don't know if y'all know this but do you
know the the guy who made Sonic mania
was actually he made a bunch of fan
games and they basically had a choice of
suing him or hiring they're like okay
he's okay
yeah well you know we we went over that
in such detail as I am so happy and
proud of him with his due diligence and
his determined his dexterity when it
came to pushing his vision and I'm so
that's why I got the ultimate edition of
it because I wanted to make sure I
should have been physical for that one
they gave you a digital for it but you
got the physical replica I had no idea I
would have done it I totally would have
done it I'm gonna get a disk on it but
um as far as sunset overdrive - this is
the problem with with Microsoft and
you're gonna continue to see this
problem with Microsoft right
you have Phil who's basically dipping
and dodging and moving and moving on the
squares that he can move he sees the
squares that are lit up and he's trying
to avoid the pitfalls they give him
certain amount of money now he has to
say to himself do I go with this field I
pinna this is burnt you already or do I
move forward and go with this because I
have to concede what you say makes sense
it wasn't a commercial success initially
not at all listen when they touted
insomniac games everybody was like oh oh
now the problem with that is insomniac
games this Jet Set grind radio type of
thing that was that was far out of their
wheelhouse
if you woulda gave me a buddy game as
like a Ratchet and Clank or Jack and
Dexter type of game I think it would
have Excel to the point and sold more
and meant people's expectations of the
insomniac brand now I know you're gonna
say there's other games that they made
that are different but what they made
the wheelhouse in was these type of
games and when this game was so
different it took people about some
people say I don't really know about
that game right there now me I purchased
the game I love the game I wish
Microsoft would pick it up but
I have any hopes of them picking it up
not at all and from what I hear the game
is at least 75% done they're just
looking for publishers and a little bit
more backing to finish it up and close
out the game dad you look wicked Lord
solves our point so what what do you
think ultimately happens and so start
with something like what do you think
happens with them or solve I think
ultimately they get picked up by some
third party publisher in the game goes
third party as would make most financial
sets I would love to see it back on
Microsoft's platform again maybe a game
that can start to really push Phil's
game past narrative about breaking up
these titles and maybe kind of
financially spreading out the cost of
the stuff to have these games live on
these systems but I you know that's
that's pie in the sky I honestly say
yeah somebody's gonna pick it up and
it'll be on everything and that'll be
fine okay we'll still get to play I
think another reason if the other
publishers are kind of holding out or
not picking it up is the fact that
you're picking up a sequel to an IP that
you can't get the original for so it's a
question of bringing a sequel onto a
system that has the people who own that
system may have no prior knowledge of
the original game and then you don't
have you don't have a basis for people
having interest in it apart from it
being an insomniac thing and when
insomniac coming out with spider-man
probably this coming year
it's it doesn't make any sense to sort
of dilute that message not you
absolutely your Lord logic has what do
you only think happens with the sunset
overdrive situation and in Capcom it's
hard to say what may end up happening is
it could end up being the where they
hand it off to another team because what
I forget is that that studio is
incredibly tiny and some yet games
excuse me and sunny at games is actually
one of the smallest Studios in the
business they have a lot of trouble even
making one game at once let alone two
games at once and like you just said
there really
really deep into spider-man right now so
it could just be very much of like they
end up giving the IP temporarily to
somebody whether it be Microsoft Sony or
Nintendo I'd be like okay you have full
permission we'll give you like 30 people
from the original team to make sure it
stays as core to the original feel but
we can't even help you with it so I
honestly think that that's a very strong
possibility as we see a sunset overdrive
to but it's very different still awesome
still funny but also polished and very
different shout out the Lord is moving
to chat he's jumping jumping he's saying
that he's saying that he's taking a cab
home will not be sold he's also saying
sunset overdrive to will be published by
505 as a multi plats real that is the
best possible move because that's what
these were a series like that deserves
mass attention but you need it on every
console so that everybody can be
promoting it and yeah that they'll be
such a great win most movie I get you
back will show me a job jump bombs I
hope that's true
no that's too big that would actually be
cool you know like I said says it over
try was my cup of tea but I don't want
to see the thing go away
you said it Microsoft can't get it then
doesn't want you know don't want it
doesn't look at it as a financial
success like walking a scene then hey by
all means go multi-platinum
let this thing continue to live you know
so that's what I got on that if any of
the laws got anything else between uh
insomnia and Capcom oh we should be
ready to move on so we got lured SWAT
back in the building and a lot of us
destiny guys here and that PC trap
launcher came out this week so what loss
what tell us about your experience with
that
you know um I have we have a lot of
people in our Pete's where they're
asking you know about the PC experience
and you know that's uncap goodness so
talks about your experiences on it I had
a lot of very good experiences with
tonight a lot of very bad so far like
one of the best things that the game
just looks phenomenal the game looks and
the frame rate it's very smooth my faith
my absolute favorite thing is that the
aim assist is finally gone I can finally
you know aim aim at one enemy shoot at
that enemy if someone runs across
the screen on PvP I'm not I'm not
dragging my my reticle back to the Versa
I almost had I almost sat down so and
also the aim-assist actually does really
make it feel a lot smoother because I
don't feel the jumpiness when with a lot
of enemies in one room I don't feel the
jump being as pulling me to aim down the
enemies you know one of the worst things
that I had with it is the text chat the
text chat is it's only with between
between fireteam pvp team and clan mates
and I think friends people in your
friends list is for Blizzard as well but
um it's very limited and there's I had a
lot of issues especially during PvP
because someone on your team might
actually give you a call out every once
in a while I tell you oh hey there's
someone behind you but you have to
actually switch over to the team chat to
actually back this unless what
so coming from a console peasant
perspective so you have to educate me
though
European tell me there's no built-in
chat interface like there's no there's
no party chat no worry big issue with
the third-party apps and disco I mean
like having overlays stuff like that's
been disabled people get banned stuff
like that because I haven't that but you
mean to tell me in-game like people it's
there's no check interface uh like voice
chat yeah like let's say you wanted to
do a strike or all right you know
together you know what I'm like how do
we set that up how would we go about
setting up in-game but what's provided
so to speak nothing wow it's which I
would have to we would actually have to
try to meet in in the tower we'd have to
try to actually see each other in the
tower and send that invite in-game
that's the only way to do anything I
like I said you have to have it as
someone on your friends list and you
have to be able to whisper them but if
it's your first time jumping on like
it's yeah yeah that's and it's you know
I actually just got like just before I
got an invite to a clan and that was
just because they saw me in the tower
they saw I was over a certain
like they just sent me an invite and so
I figured why not I'll join us see what
the clan is like I have not received any
messages prior Wow dead just dead
silence there's nothing I don't know
who's in the clan I can't see because
the clan system is bugged a lot like on
it Xbox and ps4 where when you jump into
the clan you can't it just shows the
scrollwheel they had a few little little
bugs and fear and there I had out of
instances where enemies and missions
they would just they would just be stomp
on the ground they wouldn't be shooting
they'd just be stomping you just run
right through oh I'm sorry I have a 1080
1080 monitor that has a 1440 super scale
in which it does look great like I said
the the 60 frames per second
what's that freaking vana I'm usually
running unrestricted just because with
with like patrols they're so big they're
so expansive I'd you know my graphics
card isn't you know it's not an Nvidia
1080 it's it's a our X 480 it's and it
runs it very well it's just in the
patrols where I want my field of view to
be very very far I'm seeing you know
mainly about 40 to 60 in patrol areas
you know it's it's pretty varied
basically on how far I can actually see
but with it trying to run restrict at 60
I get a lot of choppiness so I actually
running on restrict it feels a lot
better in lost sectors I see the biggest
framerate drum I'm I'm usually around
like 120 Plus on framerate just because
they're so small but uh you know
crucible is very smooth like 50 to 70
frame rate very nice you know I
definitely love this just how PvP feels
on the PC a lot for meta to like the
metas even look different based on the
feel of the game the thing is without
having the
I'm assist not every gun is gonna fall
is it doesn't have the same feeling as s
consul whereas you know hand cannon
always fires like this you know every
hand cannon could almost feel similar
because you're always kind of hitting
the same spots and that's actually
another thing with the PvE
is when I played on the console it felt
like I was just you know why I heard
Time magazine say you you know you're
running through a room filled with
balloons and you're fighting them with a
nail gun and and that was exactly how it
felt in the PC version you're not locked
into the aspect of always locking onto
the head just when you aim down and the
fact is in PCs that you're not doing
that you're not always getting the
precision damage so when you have 1020
enemies running at you and you know
you're not hitting precision shots and
getting that one-hit kill on every shank
suddenly it does feel a little bit more
difficult I do I do really enjoy that
because I really wanted a little bit
more of a difficult you know play
playing ability on on destiny - and the
console didn't feel like it had that
okay so so overall right now I'm sorry
overall right now great ah graphical
presentation you know you're only grabs
right now just like you know they gotta
get the chat the social aspects yeah I
didn't feel that on the console I feel
that on the PC and that actually did
make me feel a little bit better about
jumping on and playing cuz it didn't
just feel like I'm walking through a
mess and trying to try to get my you
know participation bonus or going
through P wait for my token oh you know
I mean I wouldn't be playing this patrol
because I'm really just sitting here
doing the same thing and it's not
difficult you know I'm just waiting for
my token so I can get my little chess
piece or whatever
no you weren't one of the Oh quick
question for you you weren't one of
those unlucky people who received the
ban hammer from Bungie I heard there was
a big woman going on you know a lot of
people with third-party apps that IVA
presents overlays to way logic I like
the way
the battlenet has it set up I believe it
was very restrictive did not allow any
code to be entered in the game so that
they were automatic yeah like kind of no
mods of any kind of any variety
instability yeah it kind of so there was
like a lot of false banhammer is going
out initial launch from what I
understand but they did less they get
that that's rectified now I'm really to
you Lord Dreamcast and I'll bring it
back no spot um obviously we just need
eyes I'm assuming you're not yeah I know
sorry go ahead was the question no no
you surprised continued so so I did not
like destiny one very much I when I
initially reviewed it I gave it a 6 out
of 10 because I felt like even though it
was so had such great gameplay such good
aiming such tight controls it was just
such an empty treadmill the same guys
walking up destiny to fixed a lot of the
problems I think I'm giving it an 8 and
I was really really impressed with the
fact that the dungeon layouts were
better the guns felt a little more fair
the way loot systems work there was so
many like genuine what do they call it a
improvement of life like just just well
and I like that so much my problem is
that I'm still not a big fan of the
rating a bunch of my real life friends
are obsessed with the rating and they'll
actually pull me in there because I'm
light level 272 so they'll just pull me
to raise occasionally so that I can try
it and I am just always like I don't
know they're they don't there's you know
complicated I never thought I'd actually
said it but they're too complicated like
okay you stand on this button and I'm
gonna write down over here right as this
giant monster comes out and pees on us
you shoot it it's too much I feel like
at the time like it's it's so it feels
like trying to pull off a giant bank
heist but I don't even get a goat a
Tripathi I hear you coming from you know
Lord Kidd could attest it like I was
terrified in the race I would never do
them the original density he's like
don't worry I got you know boobs the
core raid he dragged me and he's like
you sitting at corner I just do XYZ shot
the Lord sinister also those are those
guys made with system and it's one of
those things that I think why
it's a shame because if you have it on
the expert do we will run you through
logic like we we've got it down to a
science and it's one of those things
that yeah I do recommend you get your
light level up a little bit higher you
know so this way you can little bit more
damage and actually deal a little bit
more damage but like once you get the
first one under your belt so to speak
and you would a team like I said shout
out to channel 5 so I think you know bad
ug all you guys that's raining all our
cities you know I mean like I'm telling
you look like it is one of the best
cooperative experiences in gaming the
rain and again like shout out the Lord I
know he's not here right now like he's
like we beat this good drink like you've
got an experience you are i pinky
promise here on all that the lord's hold
dare i will give their solid rate
because yeah like I said most majority
of our clan most on Xbox but it's one of
those things like we've got guys that
are like machines you know more King
they know all the tricks all the
strategies to get that light level up
right and once you're up and in your
first raid and like I said what I like
what they do which is what I love our
squad is that they really simplify it
I'm just worried about this aspect just
do this don't worry you know like as
even talking to tell you like the
gauntlet I was messing up a thousand
times he's like no shoot the bottom I
shoot the top when this happening I'm
okay I got like so I guess what it is is
you just stick with one specific role
and then as you more and more of them
then you kind of get to expand you get
your confidence up oh okay now I see
what you do okay and I'm doing it from
this perspective now I get it okay and
then you understand like you said the
bank heist your partner to do what you
said he was gonna do that's all it's
like you have to have absolute
confidence that he's gonna get his job
done
don't worry about nobody else's job one
one job that's how that's what got me
through it and then from there they
became really enjoyable and this one is
really it's
well okay it's like this we got we gotta
get low gene cast on some xbox back to
Louis what real quick so um as far as a
PC now is a big thing going on in the
community right now that I want to ask
you I know did you do foundry touch this
you know I know the PC requirements and
the rigs you know are out there and the
big shout out the Lord Rand outdoors
just put a video out you know obviously
we know that PlayStation has the
marketing rights with destiny too and we
know that as far as the Xbox one x-man's
they have been very mom they have not
they keep saying we cannot talk about
these enhancements at this time you know
share at the digital foundry who's
actually been trying to dig one of the
Bungie devs as far as um you know just
seeing what the Xbox one X might be
capable of now I wanted to ask you Louis
why because you've played and I'm
assuming that uncap framerate and stuff
like that you know in your estimation
you're the tech lord like in your
estimation do you think maybe we we've
know they've come out with the official
statement that Bungie said 4k 30 his
consoles right but now we're seeing with
the Xbox one X and X enhanced list
coming out we're seeing a lot of games
like gears have a performance mode right
where it's 1080p 60 right we're seeing
arc we sing rise of the Tomb Raider when
they had Saudis Xbox one X list do you
think there's a chance that maybe 1080p
60 as opposed to 4k 30 or do you think
based on what you see mmm it's two
cpu-bound you don't think they might be
able to pull it off what I'm going to
detect Lord Himself loss why what's
going on I think it's more likely they
can do 1080 60 than they could ever do
4k 60 gotcha I mean like 4k right now
it's a big it's a big thing because it's
it's really it's so many I think what is
it is a four time let's sovereign help
me out here is it four times or is it
eight times more higher resolution than
when it's four yeah yeah yeah so I mean
it's it's really you know you need at
the same time if you get if you're
running you know so well at at 1080 you
you almost in like four times the amount
of CPU power in terms of that you know
it's like you really need so much in
there and right now I
don't I don't see the GPU capabilities
within the Xbox one even though they
knew we have it built right into the CPU
and that that mode of trash is capable
as to CPU that isn't because the game is
Vpu bound calculations and particle
effects and the or the triple-s housing
that is all CPU bound press the
algorithms that they give the NPC's so
um that is the only bottleneck within
the system because when I run it on PC I
see exactly what but is using PC
performance and what is using GPU
performance it's using PC CPU
performance opposed to using my GPU
because I'm dual 1080s I plays that game
I run 4k 80 frames per second no matter
what um
but I see when it's uh when we get into
open areas it gives a heavy CPU hit the
CPU is using 80 to 90 percent of my CPU
I have ice m i7 um alright and this is I
seven extreme I think inside of it so
for it to do that on that and you would
think the the equivalent on the Xbox one
X is like a i3 so yeah overclock let me
ask you this question because lost both
for you loss Spartan or King you know
obviously we were at e3 this year you to
had that exclusive access not King you
very premium at e3 first to see destiny
to 4k 60 goodness can you tell me like
what was the what was the setup they
were running them or if you know that
ease yeah there Ted there are 10 a TTI's
but I think I 777 hundreds and they ran
very smooth they were very nice funny
thing is King David is that that
actually the the one of the big
differences that I see is that since I'm
running an octa-core Bashara I'm
actually seeing a much less of a
you know hit on my CPU I'm only seeing
my CPU running about like 40 you know 40
percent up you know utilization at times
and only like maybe 19 to 20 21 to 23
degrees Celsius on my heat obviously I
have an IVA water cooler now one thing
is are you seeing like do you see over
50% of your GPU utilization do you know
what remember I'm using it I'm doing it
at 4k okay 1080 the framerate is
ridiculous this is something stupid like
200 frames per second whatever 1080p
it's it's crazy because of the CPU is so
below yeah it's like it's not using it
at all but the moment I put it to 4k and
like doubles or triples the utilization
of the CPU that is that's what the
bottlenecks come in it so know what
notes I want to get you in on this um
you know obviously you guessed include
on console um do you think there's a
shot or do you think the marketing deal
still plays into this whole bit as far
as the Xbox 1x enhancement that should
be coming soon
where are you at with that whole
situation I feel that the marketing deal
as much as people say those things don't
affect these things they obviously do
you're not holding back specs are not
talking about specs because you feel
like it there's no reason not to unless
there there's something coming from a
third party telling you know you hold
off on this so it's a media seems
obvious that something is coming um and
we'll know when the X drops what what
that is all right Tay 1086 again there
were they were games that I you know the
fact that with with gears that they just
announced a 10-8
I mean these are things that are just
coming out coming to light now or mark
survived announced 1080 60 mode so
because what is that what is low
Dreamcast is for us Xbox one the primary
that's most preferred platform here
right on the round table but the thing
is a lot of the Xbox is Microsoft
community I looked it's 4k stuff is
great right but some people are like
look I don't have a 4k TV so then that's
when they I noticed they've been kind of
promoting super sampling a lot saying
that you just didn't see any improvement
but the other thing that people are
saying is like hey we don't really care
for the 4k but if you give us 60 frames
with a less resolution you know that
they're fine with that and it looks like
a couple of these earlier titles that
we're seeing on this like I said are
available gears they just announced a
performance more at 1080 60 mode you
know so the hope is that maybe that
either through a patch later on or you
know down the road that if if possible
they can provide give the Xbox 1x these
kind of options to make it more
attractive to the let's be honest cuz
the 4k market still hasn't taken off all
the way it's we're in the early stages
of it right
not everyone has a 4k TV so to speak but
I feel at least I agree with the
community in this sense that that's a
great marketing point to say hey if you
don't got 4k boom we got a 60 frames per
second mode for you and you got super
sampling I think that would be cool what
do you think about that that whole
mindset of the community it's really
smart in a way very much this whole
thing right now it's kind of been
dawning on me over the last couple weeks
is this feels like PlayStation 2 where
it's like they come out with this new
technology and remember the early
PlayStation 2 games with DVD technology
actually were just normal PlayStation
discs because they just weren't making
that bigger games originally but after a
while then it became like okay now the
technology has fully caught up to what
our gadget can do and I think it's the
same thing here like buy this 4k capable
device and as all the studios actually
start updating their projects to be
1080p or 60 frames a second or 4k
compatible you already have it in your
living room it makes it we're like the
people who bought it just on a whim or
got as a Christmas gift are now going to
be 10 times more die-hard and people who
didn't jump Bart on board initially are
gonna be heavily swayed over of being
like man I went over to my friends house
and his game looked completely different
and we're playing through the same game
so I think this is this is future
proofing in the smartest way right now
mm-hmm absolutely absolutely I think
anything you can do to get that game to
60 frames per second on console you
should do regardless I mean it has some
sort of dynamic resolution scaling like
you have with Halo 5 like whatever the
case may be
do what you need to do to get that game
to 60 frames per second on that console
and trust me that people will flock to
it there's a question now what if they
just didn't advertise it as being 60
locked what if they just said oh we'll
let you run it on restrict the framerate
drops that's where it is
I think they that's a big a big
opportunity right there too because I
mean then you know you could tell people
I mean then people could have the choice
of running on restricted on you know
maybe 4k would be restricted to 30 just
to keep it you know stable but then just
throw it on 1080 and say oh yeah run it
on restricted cuz obviously you could do
4k 30 it can definitely do you know 1080
basically anything I would hope so I
hope so you want to jump in for me more
yeah yeah now I would hope so I mean
that's the only thing like I said
because I feel that again in the Xbox
community there's a lot of people who I
see who are very interested in the X but
again they like hey I don't have a 4k TV
right now so it's really not a priority
shot at the Brat podcast and those guys
you know he's one of the guys that I
respect and he you know he said that
like hey I just don't have the need for
writing down the role but I think offer
these frame per second loads and you
know they really I think that could be a
huge sale I think Microsoft could really
take advantage of that if you know they
start promoting those options you know
Xbox one exciting
frame per second so trust me is the
sources in the CPU is going to take
control anyway either get less you know
chugs here and there or less graphical
glitches when you do overlays this is a
better experience from what I've seen a
lot of stuff that they've been running I
try not to look at too many people's
unboxings and impressions because I want
to be wild myself when I own bonds but
from what I've been seeing from the
early fortunate few shout out to you
guys you're blessed
that's people that you definitely have a
certain people because I don't
appreciate that
but I know what Phil is doing that's
what I'm gonna give you your guys reason
why I understand a lot of the Xbox
capisci guys let me just give you guys
the context apparently um there's been a
lot of people been getting the Xbox 1x
early you know um a lot of people in the
community that are hard core have been
pretty vocally upset because I guess the
people who receive these you know Xbox
1x were very kind to the Xbox one in
there as far as their review during the
early stages of the cycle so you know
what's happening is you have people like
hey you guys these guys Bosch the brand
you know we're guys that got a flag out
we rep this hard like we should have got
it and I understand that I understand
the emotional aspect of it like you know
a guy that was bashing a product that
you you know you really support and
you've been championing gets it ahead of
you but the other thing you gotta look
at it like this and I always taught this
about Laura saw is remember when Xbox
one X I thought was genius they gave a
console reveal to digital
Foundry I thought that was genius in the
reason why because let's be honest with
digital friendly comes on logic as
Richard Ledbetter he does that British
voice it's very very smooth and he
reviews your frame rate he tells you how
it drops in its spike then a lot of the
Xbox one versions versus the PlayStation
versions it did not compete right the
PlayStation version multi-platform game
tended to eighty this percent of the
time and resolution better or what have
you
right so to me when Microsoft did that
to me that should ultima confidence in
the product right I'm gonna give it to
one of our harshest critics for them to
review they have this exclusive story
and the way I look at it in shout the
portal rock 77 he's got a good video out
right now y'all gotta check him out I
gotta get him on a show is that he
actually said it like it doesn't benefit
them like to give it to the cuz you know
ultimately these guys are experts got
they're gonna love them run up you have
to get the people who are on the fence
who didn't necessarily like the product
to say you know what this might not be
too bad you know I mean that's how you
kind of change things no but what do you
think about this logically this is a hot
topic now I'm gonna add this to the end
of the show well what do you think about
that that whole mindset I think I'll
kind of forget that companies usually
choose the people very strategically who
they want to have their product like
well an interesting thing they when they
were giving out Nintendo switches
obviously earlier this year they gave
some to the really big guys but they
also gave a lot to the really really
small youtubers and stuff who are like
ten fifteen thousand subs like something
normally wouldn't even get a free game
and that's because they're trying to
really get this what they call in the
business a temperature they want to get
a bunch of people so they get a what
they consider a fair average so it could
just be that they want to give some to
the Xbox haters and see if they could
win them over and some to the really
hardcore Xbox channels who they know
we're gonna give it a ten out of ten
like I myself actually I talked to
Microsoft trying to get one and I didn't
I actually specifically said like hey
I'm Dreamcast guy I get like a million
views a month I'd like to check this out
and they were like actually we just ran
out unfortunately but all my face
all my friends in Canada got one so it's
the things where I think they're I think
they're being very careful with like
maybe better they get a very fair skew
yeah that's a good point that's a good
point into your defense
I mean you actually came out with a
video recently about why you know you
feel like the switch in the Xbox one why
did they get hated on you know me and I
always looked at you as a balanced voice
so I think they I think honestly I don't
think you should take it anyway because
they look at you as one of those they
call you a filthy neutral so like I feel
like I feel like it's a good reviewer
you have to be extremely neutral I feel
like I always say like a good reviewer
can walk into a game they hate and if
it's good give it a good review whereas
like a bad reviewer back no I hate got a
war and even though there's new god of
War's a masterpiece I've given it a 2
out of 10 so a lot of times I try and I
review stuff on every console I own
every console I play every console that
way I can look at every console even
your feelings on that whole the Xbox the
my community a little upset at it fill
in these guys have given up these
systems I mean it's there there's a
limited supply it's it's it's free you
know release they they need a certain
amount that's gonna be going to the
public but you know these guys are gonna
be buying an Xbox one X anyway all right
that's ten I mean you're I'm 100% with
you you know you gotta take you got to
go out and to really provide that you
know this voice of hey this is actually
gonna be something more tape look at you
have to go and find these people that
didn't champion the project the product
the project and the product and all that
you have to go and and let them feel it
for themselves and say hey actually this
this is good enough that it sways me and
when people read back see that they'll
say you know what if it if it's suede
this person that I love I respected I
look up to he's always been checking up
yes before the or this other brand actor
no suddenly he said that this is
actually better maybe I should actually
consider it
i'ma give you a different perspective
all right let's go
um they looked at your email they looked
at it linked to Amazon they looked at
and lifted Best Buy or whatever you know
when you pre-order it and if you know I
feel you tuber or you have a channel or
Twitter or whatever and they seen if you
pre-ordered it now if you are you know a
hater
probably wasn't getting it anyway now
why send it to somebody who already
pre-ordered it anyway right send it to
somebody who wasn't gonna get it who did
yeah or if they were gonna get it any
we're gonna get it later after you know
the price drop because I heard crazy
stuff and those guys can actually say
well I got it and it's more than I
expected and you know I don't have a 4k
television but what is doing for super
sample it's incredible and push those
guys to the front to change the
narrative that's in the streets right
now because I remember I tell you people
tend to say things that aren't true but
if you said enough you get enough people
saying it a lot of people believe you so
when you change the narrative of what's
going on with Microsoft because
everybody suck my all Microsoft is
feeling what are you talking about it's
not fair saying it people perceive it to
be that way and it might happen
Mike's exact but I'm doing just fine I
think public consensus was what killed
the PSP early on people realized the PSP
has no games everyone used to spell it
them got no games headline and even
though I actually I own hundreds of PSP
games it's one of my favorite game
consoles to collect for handhelds to
click for it but man it sunk it as soon
as people started being like yeah
interested in the PSP but it doesn't
have any games and people said that
about Xbox one all the time now like I
want to get an Xbox one but there's just
no games like are you high was one state
once they they broke it open and people
were putting you know their entire yes
catalog on it then it became popular for
a different reason other than yep Sony's
own games but I think the
Xbox thing yeah I think it's a lot sorry
K and yet he had a braaap rant about
this I think day ago or two days ago and
yeah I mean it just makes sense like you
have to and you have to look at
followers to whether you're a hater or
not I mean if you have you know fifty
thousand subs you want to get something
into their hand so that they can have an
opinion and again it's about giving it
to people who you know if they've been
hard on you then at least fair at least
fair and if they're out there and just
said you know championing Sony
championing Nintendo and just like
shooting down everything they come back
but you don't want to give it to that
person because it's just gonna be it's
just it's just gonna be negativity you
know I don't Dreamcast guy said
something specific about this how people
spend more time hating on someone else's
love of something rather long showing
enjoying yeah that is that that's just
the truth of the Internet but the fact
of the matter is is it yeah you have to
get into somebody's hands who's been
critical of your product but you know is
still it's gonna be fairly objective
when they get it into the hands and
again if you're confident in it you
should see some positive results in that
you know I people who you don't listen
you're gonna buy it you're gonna love it
don't get mad at the fact that they
didn't give you one it's just ridiculous
I mean it was business and I'm gonna
always it you know when it comes to
business you get the business decision
the right decision is to give it to the
people they can get the most opinions
about it out facts we're gonna wrap this
thing up again thanks everyone for
sticking around apologies on that late
star but shout out the Lord Dreamcast
game and for coming through cast
roundtable huge fan you guys have been
freaking awesome this has been a
freaking blast seriously thank you and
thank you to chat y'all have been
awesome providing cool questions cool
feedback y'all helped it a state hop hop
and this was so fun thank you for having
me on
absolutely you always welcome back we're
gonna wrap this thing up real quick but
um just to couple things before we gotta
pay the bills also so I'm just real
quick
the new poll this
we'll be up when I launch podcast
Twitter little later on we're gonna have
the it's gonna be the murderers row
October poll
so which combination of the murderers
row do we think finishes one in two in
October's and PD will be Mariota
Assassin's Creed Marilyn Wolfenstein or
Wolford started assassins great so again
it could be like I said they don't have
to necessarily finish one and two
respectively in the MPD but which
combination of the three together finish
higher that that's pretty much what the
question is so make sure you guys uh
Rock the Vote
that's the question those are the
choices record go get the IOP Twitter
polls and real quick Mia's gonna pay the
bills right quick shoutout to
Plantronics um like Lord King Sandman
home definitely trying to champion these
products I mean they sent us these uh
the Dolby the rigs the dolby atmos rigs
great series we're gonna try to come up
with some reviews for that very soon
we're gonna get online Africa's miss
involved with that little King you guys
have that premium 800 what are you the
LX the same thing I'll put that the
Plantronics made high quality great
sound dolby atmos y'all you know I know
a lot of people say software that's cool
but it's really it really sounds great
so um yeah just wanna wrap this thing up
we gonna do our outro so on your
Dreamcast again thank you for coming
through absolute pleasure where can the
fine people find you and what do you
have cooking up for us to keep dreaming
about alright so just find me a
youtube.com slash dreamcast guy tomorrow
is gonna be a heck of a doozy
tomorrow morning I'm having my Mario
Odyssey review going up probably around
9 a.m.
really excited really kind of get that
out there teaser it's freaking amazing
and then I'm actually spending the rest
of today working on a big Assassin's
Creed video which should be available
tomorrow afternoon so
is gonna be a double up to load of epic
impressions and the Tuesday III as a kid
totally true story I had a haunted
giggles as a kid so I'm gonna tell the
story of that for Halloween wow that's
dope
I gotta check that yeah I'm looking
forward to this bed I'm a high one it's
constantly turning on by itself in fact
actually when I was possessed
I'm blaming you can't man and yet always
does some crazy during our gaming
sessions no actually he's pretty funny
if we ever turned the ps4 he'll walk up
and turn it off actually turn it on and
then leave it on I think he likes the
white light and then my PC I was saying
in chat earlier he kept trying to turn
it off because the power button is lit
up with a red ring and he'll sit there
and smack it and try to turn it off
wicked the fine people find you first of
all big shout out to dreamcast guy for
coming through man like honestly you're
a man after our own heart because you
know most of us on the podcast we're 80s
and 90s kids so it's great to have
people sort of parallel our experiences
and in that regard you're living the
dream because I wish I could go play
sasses Creed today for tonight we really
appreciate it
and then the fine people can find me on
Twitter at Lord saw IO p + bx sovereign
on p.m. PSN and xbox live
absolutely lost offerings being online
if profiles of online as we go
lord kick wicked upon people find you oh
I like to give a shout out to Lord
Dreamcast guy listen man
wisdom tooth didn't keep me away from
stitches in the mouth I'm talking like
fantastic you wouldn't know anything
different experience but I'm here I'm
coherent I'm 100% ready to get it in
because nothing was keeping me away from
this guy I swear um
watch yourself I love your stuff I love
your reviews and being neutral isn't bad
but you have good opinions on a lot of
stuff so you know to hell with it it
works
um you can find me on Instagram Twitter
Facebook all that other great stuff but
I would like to say next week it's going
to be a great week and combat sports
people please tune and we have our
American fighters going at it on
Showtime if you have Hulu watch it on
Hulu live it's fantastic and we also
have UFC UFC I would like Laura kognito
just to give you a tidbit of what's
going on in the UFC I know what's going
on but y'all it's gonna be a George st.
Pierre and um it's gonna be Michael
Bay's being put the mouse Madison Square
Gardens that this showcase is gonna be
spectacular great undercard as well but
that's the main card in our I'll chime
in on when the Lord of Commerce was does
his intro I'll try don't solve the child
so that'll be fun the Lord SWAT one of
the original Halo it's always a pleasure
to have you back on man where can people
find you I could find me on Twitter I'd
SWAT force five um you know I'm not
really I haven't really been on was a
twitch yeah I've really been on twitch
too much lately
just kind of been a little busy with
work and all that but you can find me on
on twitch at bullet ring and like I said
well we're coming for you for more PC
updates down the road shout out to the
Apple Twitter
rattled asking for requesting lost
weddings he was hot out here they like
is he gonna talk PC I got it he's gone
that's good of course it's little
cockney know here's right now getting
runners on the ILP not telling you what
you wanna hear but what you need to hear
so again like I said please hit that
like to subscribe to ILP and all the
inner circle Network media outlets if
you missed tic podcast last night at a
great section on shore you know the
whole thing with pubs
great topics Kyle anchorman be money to
trifecta the trio make sure you guys hit
them up and then obviously a brother
podcast will multiverse they'll be up on
Monday nights at 8 p.m. we got great
contact here at tick the amazing tech
GaN creature on links in the description
all the support really help your chat
was lit y'all thank you very much what a
chat chat was never seen a lot of new
faces interacted it was really really
cool and thanks rock on and so on that
note we're gonna end the show then we're
at peace